did you catch the multiple nods to tony
stark in the she-hulk attorney at law
trailer how about the titaniacs or
frogmen keep watching for these
split-second moments and more
in the comics jennifer walters was your
average los angeles lawyer until crime
boss nicholas trask shot her in a bid to
get revenge on her dad her cousin bruce
banner happened to be in town at the
time and gave her a life-saving blood
transfusion it turns out that gamma rays
are definitely bloodborne because
bruce's blood made jennifer the super
strong super durable she-hulk she
retains her wit and intelligence after
hulking out though which is only
sometimes true for her cousin the
trailer for she-hulk attorney at law
hints that all that backstory has
already happened in the mcu early in the
trailer there's a brief shot of a car
crashing into some underbrush though it
initially seems like that may be the
traumatic event that leads to the blood
transfusion we later see jennifer's face
turning green before a reflection in her
dented car door reveals her she-hulk
form it seems she's already got her
gamma blood or the transfusion happened
right then and there like in the comics
the relationship between bruce and
jennifer appears to be close-knit there
are flashes of bruce mentoring jennifer
and teaching her how to control her
powers including him waking her up with
an airhorn
yes yes yes
no no
the first place we see bruce and jen
working together is a beautifully lush
tropical hideaway an even more
interesting environment appears a few
seconds later in a high-tech facility
possibly underneath the tropical getaway
given their attire bruce advises
jennifer on how to transform into
she-hulk a helmet appears to monitor her
brainwaves during the transformation
bruce decides the best way to force
jennifer to transform and test her
strength is to send a wall of spinning
blades at her before they start up you
can see the first few letters of what
appears to be the stark industries logo
before they're activated given the many
technologically advanced devices present
including those stark blades it seems
possible this could be a stark
industry's funded lab of some kind at a
minimum this suggests bruce has kept
some ties to stark industries even after
the death of tony stark the late
avengers technologies have made several
appearances in the mcu including in
spider-man far from home
at one point in the she-hulk attorney at
law trailer she falls back onto a bed in
what looks like a mix of defeat and
exasperation behind her head is a poster
for a production of william
shakespeare's a midsummer night's dream
so she loves theater great but more
importantly it teases one of the most
iconic she-hulk villains from the comics
there's a character in the play called
titania queen of the fairies she gets
into a fight with her husband oberon
which drives much of the main plot it
just so happens that titania is also the
name of a she-hulk super villain who
will be played by jamila jamil in the
upcoming series you can actually catch a
quick glimpse of jamil in character
later on in the trailer as the two get
into a tussle in what appears to be a
courthouse it's a fun nod to a super
villain finally getting her live-action
debut and foreshadows things to come for
jennifer
the avengers get a shout out in the
she-hulk trailer proving that even after
avengers end game they're still on
everyone's mind but jennifer walter's
take on the team isn't particularly
reverent she's clearly poking fun at
earth's mightiest heroes near the end of
the trailer jennifer's friend nikki
suggests that she-hulk could be one of
the avengers which jen finds rather
comical that is for billionaires and
narcissists and adult orphans for some
reason
the billionaires and narcissists part
seems to be directed at the late tony
stark who sure did fit the bill in july
1980s the savage she-hulk number six
jennifer walters actually questions tony
stark in court over his weapons dealings
so comics gen certainly had an axe to
grind at one point the adult orphans
part though could be directed at any
number of avengers
the she-hulk attorney of law trailer
doesn't shy away from calling back to
the hulk franchise's past as expected
bruce banner features prominently on the
show but so does one of his greatest
rivals emil blonsky better known as the
abomination the former military man pops
up in the teaser a couple of times in
both his human and monster forms
confined to a maximum security prison
cell if you forgot about this villain
tim roth made his first appearance as
blonsky in 2008 the incredible hulk
giving edward norton's moody hulk a run
for his money but ultimately lost he
ended up imprisoned at the vault and
stayed there for over a decade
surprisingly abomination returned in
2021's chongqi and the legend of the 10
rings at the golden daggers club where
he and long have been rigging fights
together
maybe you'll start controlling those
punches like we practice
in a true blink and you'll miss it
moment in the trailer a character that
looks an awful lot like frogman appears
introduced in 1965 frogman was
originally francois leblanc an olympic
level athlete who joined the villainous
anime team
however the arguably more popular
version of the character is eugene
patilio who reinvents frogman as a more
heroic figure eugene's father was once
known by the supervillain name leapfrog
eugene took on that name before
reconsidering his life of crime and
becoming the heroic frogman instead many
of frogman's victories in the comics
come from sheer luck rather than skill
and the character is often played for
laughs however his suit does contain
advanced technology that allows him to
jump far and high which is part of what
makes his superhero name so apt it's not
entirely clear if the character in the
trailer is meant to be frogman leapfrog
or someone else entirely but the
resemblance to the comic book character
is undeniable
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the mcu are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]
you